las vegas stations have a talented
roster arguably one of the best in the
league there's no debate they have some
terrific role models who are willing to
put smiles on the faces of young fans
kevin martin has that story tonight
this was kennedy breelan's reaction when
her mother surprised her with an asia
wilson jersey her all-time favorite
player i like want to be like her
someday but that was just the beginning
of the surprise kennedy soon learned she
was also going to watch asia and the
aces in action against the atlanta dream
it was just a great moment it didn't
take long for the video to go viral on
twitter catching the attention of the
entire basketball world including the
las vegas aces everybody at my school
saying i'm famous and whatever and if
the surprise ended here kennedy would
have made the trek back home to south
carolina with lasting memories but it
didn't and when the game ended i i had
no words it's crazy that
she even had that reaction to me i think
i was just as excited and shocked as she
was and even though the 12 year old was
at a loss of words she did have one
pressing question for the former league
mvp i asked her to ask becky if she
could draft me when i'm of age to play
in the wnba and that's when we revealed
to kennedy that there was yet another
surprise well that's a great question
and
instead of
you know asking asia why don't you ask
becky hi there
hey
and yet again kennedy was speechless but
head coach becky hammond wasted no time
learning about her hopeful future draft
pick and how tall are you not that it
matters because i'm super short
i'm five six and a half
me too well you know what you should
send some film in and we'll take a good
look at you we'll get back in touch
sound good okay so while kennedy has
years before her time comes right now
she has memories to last a lifetime
anything else that i love that would
probably be the number one thing that
stays in my heart forever kevin martin
live local now
all right great story thank you very
much kevin